in a meeting last week to talk about
immigration policy and we all know this
president Trump referred to Haiti and
African countries as [ __ ] countries
now according to witnesses at the
meeting the president singled out the
country of Haiti in particular saying
why do we need more Haitians now I have
no idea what the president has against
the people of Haiti but as I've said the
last few nights if the president doesn't
like them they must be lovely people
that's why I've decided to go visit with
the people of Haiti say hello try to
make some friends
it's another travel show it's gonna be
called Conan in Haiti that's the car
what I'd like to do
what I'd like to do I'd like to
introduce myself to the people of Haiti
formally and so I've asked a gentleman
named Lou Louie to help me out all right
you all set you ready ready okay here we
go
hello people of Haiti don't swap up I
said
my name is Conan O'Brien normally Conan
O'Brien I am a talk show host in the
United States medicine webassembly okok
I'll be not bothered again that's right
a big celebrity in the United States
Western want a misaki seat that magas
mimimum body will seem to be loving what
we're saying I will be coming down to
your beautiful country visiting new new
Papa's can sit on one leg I have made
similar trips to Cuba Armenia South
Korea and Israel I love you Peggy but
men keep in viña POV whether my goal is
to amuse and entertain you
xenovia and web is a Newport mask you
love this fire
must be translating this perfectly I
look forward to meeting new friends
let me put new posture next are some war
Valen I have thoroughly studied up on
Haiti boa systems in total corners where
Tara Tara who so she can configure
neckla I'm especially looking for the
sampling hades famous Creole cuisine
booty no Pema keep it okay ketchup so
I'll see you all very soon in Haiti
what's your purpose is to do me good
blossoming sooner
thank you sir
you